how's it going reject nation i'm excited
to finally be doing a reaction to
undoubtably
one of the best youtube channels
ever ever ever his name is mr sunday
movies sunday
he started up this series guess this
movie
by this terrible review it's hilarious
he just
went out a few days ago guessed the dc
movie by the terrible reviews so i
thought it'd be fun to play along give a
reaction and these two are just so
[ __ ] funny
they're they're so damn hilarious
seriously if you haven't subscribed to
mr sunday movies do yourself a favor
because they are the better australian
versions of john or not
that's right let's go that's right grab
that jimmy guys see you next week
i really enjoy these videos and i feel
like people coming here also enjoy these
videos i might enjoy this video too as
soon as you explain to me what it is
what we're doing
we love coming back to this is guess the
movie from the terrible review oh good
yes i do love this
this is dc edition oh my goodness okay
leading up to 184
getting in that algorithm making it hot
making it fresh
[Music]
in advance are they all joker i will say
there's a minimum one joker okay
but maybe there's more joker okay great
that's really up to you
if people could leave a like that would
be great yeah maybe one of those people
who gets to like in early did you beat
me to doing it
well done you're the big winner so here
we go these are all bad reviews all
right
dc movies but maybe off goodwill see if
we can get some of these all right here
we go
johannes evans the joker is meant to be
funny
obsessed with banging and or killing
batman this joke about
zero to three obviously
well here's the thing this could be the
movie joker and we're talking about
director todd phillips yes but it could
just be this guy's friend todd
no how about this one this is from
sellin boo
joker should have been rhinos acting
like deadpool
i mean agreed obviously suicide squad is
about my best guess it's balls
look at these balls suicide's good dark
knight
[Music]
[Applause]
i think ryan reynolds could probably be
a good joker under the right
circumstances
but that joke wow
[Music]
a dc movie with women in it maybe he's
referring to yeah
lois lane you know it's gotta be pretty
afraid
exactly maybe he's referring to katana
who of course as you know
it's got your back she's got your back
and she and you better watch out for her
because she's got a sword that
steal the cells of the victims or
whatever yeah because she's got your
back that's right yeah but i think it's
i've completely lost my train of thought
it's wonder woman it is wonderful but
yeah
what one that i got wrong wow
it's the exact same as the first movie
but worse than
every single one that's from brian
wishart
so it's it's the same as the first movie
is it a sequel to a movie or is it just
are they are they like this is worse
than the first dc movie ever made
yeah i'm going to say exam tv movie yeah
batman retreats
or no batman or robin i found that on my
computer the other day and i'm like oh
that was
that was a tough watch whoa we've got a
video on it we should watch more of
those
i've never seen that one well anyway
i'm guessing batman for having a robin
yeah but i think i think you're trying
to throw me off with that
probably right yeah
i think it is justice league
it's high school musical too i'm sorry i
don't know how that got in there
i apologize like now just re i realized
i should have oh no that
see in my mind what about this one i can
see the reflection
in your eyes i can see that beautiful
beautiful zac efron
tgw oh i'm sorry i don't understand how
any idiot could like this film
this movie sucks because of one thing
it's dc
all dc wow with the exception of batman
v superman uh that's not a question that
was maybe like you picked that one
uh marvel makes good films marvel has
never made a movie that wasn't good
people say hulk isn't good but it's
marvel so it is
i'm sorry but almost all dc films suck
sorry
1 out of ten stars and gives it half a
star which if you look at the ratio is
the correct amount of stuff aquaman
he's talking at the drive through he's
still getting it
uh i reckon it's shazam it's batman 1999
wow wow what people usually go back and
forth
but i think it's fine we also did a
video on it what about this one mason
uh it's from mustafa the first one was
enjoyable
not great but enjoyable this sucks
i have new respect for justice league
now seriously
nothing works here just the iconic music
airlines literally that's it and that's
only because the arrowverse pays
homage to it oh my god the arrowverse
pays homage to it
constantly is there a sequel i'm
forgetting about
music it's got hot hot bops
suicides i mean now that i've said it
it's probably not because normally the
hints i give you aren't helpful
is it batman v superman it's like
you there you've got lines if it gives
you more respect
will upset me i mean i mean justice
league i really need great lines from
that movie yeah fair enough
i forgot the review yeah like wait a
minute
it seemed like bvs at the time it's
superman too
damn you people all right i'm gonna only
guess old ones
i like that movie i know you don't like
those movies i like that movie
yeah i regret it any of these right here
i've seen this film
brackets there was no audio what
you see this movie why do we have
that well these are all of them maybe
direct them to your local cinema chain
who's
just sending you movies with no audio
maybe direct them to the av cable that
you've got unplugged
it's not helpful if i read this it might
help you i've seen
why not
hot streak in the sense that i keep
saying suicide squad that'll be the
birth of the mask of the phantasm
dark knight damn it damn damn it what
about this one
david how could he catch a bus by the
windshield worst movie ever oh that's
going to be
shazam 25
[Music]
in such an abrupt manner would turn the
bus into an accordion and the passengers
would be mush
and why did we hear a loud bang if he
caught the glass wouldn't it be the
glass
why was there a shock wave in the snow
on the ground if the bus
never actually reached the ground i know
he couldn't fly at that point in the
movie
but why didn't he just super speed up to
the bridge and grab the bus in behind
and gently pull it back up garbage
enthusiasts there's a bunch of
enthusiasts there's a favorite review
transport enthusiast is obvious
uh it's because he's magic yes that that
is the answer yeah
uh also after reading that i'm like
that's an insane review but it's by
david f
sandberg yeah directed the movie
that is fun oh this one mason
i hate to be that guy giving this half a
star but i legit cannot think of one
good thing about this film
nigel you're gonna have to make up for
it big time for making me watch this
this is one of those refer to a friend
that nobody else knows
forever
[Music]
i think this movie is a good one but
this guy just doesn't get it batman
returns
it's bird surprise
forgot what happens in this movie they
should have kissed though i tend to
agree
batman v superman yes they should have
kissed
who knows whether this will go in when i
used to uh put this stuff on
comicbookmovie.com website
one of the mandates from warner brothers
that came down was when the pictures
started to be released for batman v
superman and there was like that sad
batman picture oh yeah
don't post any of the imagery of batman
and superman like together like hugging
that people made like the fan arts okay
and like the fun little memes they were
like don't post any of that this is
serious and don't ruin our seriousness
that was from this that works no way
stop when you tell them
the writers of the batwoman comic quit
the comic because they wanted batwoman
to marry her long-term girlfriend
yeah and they said well like you can't
do that and people were outraged
and dc were like um actually it's
because um
no no dc superheroes can get married
because
um where was this this was a few years
ago they're constantly getting married
well they say characters can't get
married because it's it's better if
they're
sad and that's too happy for them people
are like
what about aquaman and mirror they're
the king and queen of atlantis they're
like
ah they're not married so they're just
what about that is a weird factor
partnership that led
are often married yeah mostly married
it's good stuff right i guess they're
wrong
maybe they were like a post superman
lost line that's the other people can
get married yeah
i can't remember who you talk about here
we go gabriella two left
somehow manages to ruin wonder woman
justice league justice league
and the very last one a half star
obviously rich white boy cries on the
door
everybody else is dealing with bigger
problems and we're not talking about
bloody donald trump mates
finally somebody got it
[Music]
it's a guy on the golf course yeah
something something well everything
crumbles
oh god batman i don't know one of the
batman's high school musical too
i'm sorry i don't know how they got in
there because they're just slipping
their way here
son of a [ __ ]
anyways i hope people enjoyed this sorry
for getting political but i had to make
a great joke
well this was in a lot of games this was
all the setup
every misstep where you thought actually
i didn't know what the movie was because
i'm
i'm some sort of doofus it doesn't know
anything about movies she was always
funneling us towards that group it's so
cute
i didn't look at them but i'm like yeah
i couldn't find one that i really felt
about trick you enough
[Music]
and that one that's half a star it's
like why didn't the joker throw that
grenade like in the trailer i'm so mad
about it
oh yeah yeah we're all mad about that
anyways well how do people go
what did they get did you get the
elusive high school musical once
uh by the way don't feel bad
but uh if you if you do have any link
them below because i love doing these
they're designed to make you contemplate
removing that line
but don't kick the like on if you
haven't give it a like
you know give it a like also we do
videos here all the time don't we mason
absolutely every sunday
tuesday thursday i don't know at this
point mate who knows i got a baby
i finally learned it i finally learned
the secrets
and you've changed it probably it's at
least sunday or tuesday okay cool
also we have a podcast called the weekly
planner where we talk movies and comics
and tv shows but we have a service it's
called big sandwich dot co we can sign
up for early videos
bonus podcasts ad free feed movie
commentaries we've done most of the dc
movies haven't we must
rise good stuff yeah good stuff
how do you think we have yet we should
do that we're throwing wonder woman up
there as well aren't we that's right
probably there by now anyways thanks for
watching this we appreciate it
uh grab that gem everybody we'll see you
next week goodbye
[Music]
you know what's funny they do have their
podcast i haven't gone over to actually
listen to the podcast
yet actually i listened to their most
recent podcast yesterday and it was
hilarious
watch it or listen that's the correct
term every time i
end one of these i'm like i gotta just
start listening to the podcast i usually
only listen like the first time i heard
i
guessed this review this specific
segment i remember i was shopping at
ralph's i was just like
laughing while i was in the aisles
that's so much so much of the jokes they
were making i
constantly forget how well edited
these videos are too i mean it says
right here matthew thomason who edits
these he does such a great job here
like so much different footage compiled
together and for just the perfect
comedic timing to match with their
comedic timing oh yeah
and i forgot how hilarious they are
because i usually am listening to mr
sunday movies i'm not actually watching
the videos
yeah and this just makes me feel like an
[ __ ] now this whole time i could have
been appreciated some great visual humor
and i've just been neglecting it because
i'm
the only time i do with anything
undivided attention is with this camera
exactly
i love the aside little animations and
stuff they throw in especially when it's
like about them so you get like a little
mason or a little mr sunday like you
know
all the different public transport
images and stuff but this is just a
terrific game
too because i mean some of them are
painfully obvious and then the ones that
aren't really get you going and they're
i mean i was all all off on all of these
yeah like every time i went for
something recent
it was a review for something old and
every time i went for something oh it
was something new i don't know i feel
like you could lose yourself
for hours just combing through these
like these this looks like a fun
video to compile everything for and yeah
ultimately select which ones are gonna
make it in you know but their chemistry
is just so damn great and i don't know
how much of their actual talking is
edited
because it just sounds so natural and
fluid and the timing is just so
it just seems so whiplash fast you know
every once in a while they do like these
really creative videos too like they had
that famous
star wars video going around where they
brought the
original episode nine to life but then
every once in a while they just do these
amazing breakdown videos too so yeah mr
sunday movies is hilarious with this
specifically this segment that they have
between him and mason
and james his name's nick mason why's it
called mason
just call him nick you know it's that
last name familial thing that's the
thing too is when i found out his name
was like oh
his his first name is an even firstier
name than his first name last year
that kind of blew my mind a little bit
but yeah it's nick to me it's
disrespectful you damn aussies
disrespecting your friends calling them
by their first name
every video from now on of ours is gonna
be alba humphrey yeah what's up
i mean the high school musical bits were
really funny i don't know how the hell
am i supposed to get that that david
sandberg won i mean you learn a lot in
these that's the funny thing is you get
like educated
but then you also a lot you laugh a lot
and you get educated
simultaneously what more can you ask for
exactly and i love i mean if that wasn't
like a cat williams show
you need a companion just to look stuff
up on the side they're the cat williams
of australia
there you go that's the that's perfect
the cat williams if cat williams was
also the real rejects of australia
if that was a real comment from david f
sandberg that just makes me all the
happier too to know that he was in his
own comment thread with like
something that for a second i believed
would would absolutely be something
someone would complain about and if
again if that's really his comment i
think that's pretty hilarious well it's
just a brilliant visual joke on how that
was assembled this is what i mean by
the two of them james and mason nick
nicholas
but then with the editor working
together because it starts off where
it's just like a paragraph
and then they do the fade reveal he
realizes this is a very
long breakdown then you get that
additional punch
that it was david f samberg the whole
time yeah the joe goes to david of
samurai but in terms of the reveal the
commentary on it like that's
like their their comedy skills are
brilliant as informative as they are
and as awesome as their breakdowns are
too i think in terms of like the movie
sphere of like doing the breakdowns and
reviews and stuff
i love red letter media a hell of a lot
the fact that these guys put out videos
weekly
and they're still so damn funny yeah all
the time
it's very impressive to me so yeah mr
sunday movies is just a
brilliant channel guys if you haven't
done so already do yourself a favor
subscribe to them click that
notification
bell hit the like button on this video
if you haven't done so already last but
not least
fox want to shout out fox today i've
been getting to know
fox over patreon messages lately learn
some really fun
albeit slightly horrific stories but
with a hilarious edge to them
about clyde's clydesdales horse the
horse thingy
big workhorses from the budweiser
commercial yeah
like some crazy stories there workout
fitness
obsessed this individual is watch i
gotta be honest though we've been
talking for a little bit of time
and uh i didn't know until today you're
actually a cisgendered female
there's no profile pick on this
individual all right it's a picture of a
fox
and for some reason you know i i didn't
what gender are you by the way cis
females
i know i should have asked and not that
it's changed the way we converse with
each other
i'm not like whoa let me reevaluate all
these messages we've had so far
completely differently in light of this
i just thought that was i was like oh
here's your female i don't know i don't
i don't know what to do with it it
doesn't really impact
anything but for some reason it was just
it was a moment on my end it was a big
deal he was like i don't know what to do
now i don't know how to connect with
this person women what
what are those i could have easily kept
this about everything else we've talked
about but for some reason i've
i've gone down this path wait who are
you
dewey cox yeah dude i love your movie
underrated definitely that sincerity fox
thank you so much for being part of this
channel
it's been great getting to know you i
love all the tips you've been giving you
have some fascinating stories
your support means a lot
[Music]
milady